context is everything
because when i say that something like
umbrella academy is trash
i mean that as a very high compliment
[Applause]
[Music]
there's nothing wrong with trash
entertainment
it's what i tend to think of instead of
using the phrase guilty pleasure because
while the general idea behind guilty
pleasure is
fine the wording throws me off i don't
think you should be
guilty about anything that brings you
joy so long as it's not something that
hurts other people
so i don't see guilt as being something
that should be part of your
entertainment diet and how you process
but that doesn't mean that some things
aren't just
they're just not high art and that's
fine
in fact that can be incredibly fun
and i'll be honest i've kind of been
jonesing
for some trash lately because
i feel like i haven't had good trash not
to my tastes
in a little bit now gotham was my go-to
trash show for a while but
that ended and unfortunately the final
season wasn't even that good
there's other things out there my
partner liz got into
um riverdale uh she's quite enjoyed that
as a trash show it's not really my
wheelhouse
although i do enjoy her telling me about
it god
her recounting the events of that show
that is entertaining in and of itself
but
what do i mean by my trash well when
we talk about geeky materials there's
certainly
plenty of options there's lots of fun
trashy stuff
in the geek sphere every and that's not
even new
like you could go back to the original
conan the barbarian stories that's
trash but it's fun trash
but i do have a specific particular kind
of flavor that's hard for me to define
except
by comparatives this is not my trash
this is not my trash this is not my
trash
this is my trash this is my trash
this is my trash
and with its second season umbrella
academy
very firmly has assumed his place as my
current favorite piece of trash
entertainment
that is going on right now so
what do i mean when i say it's trash
well
it has a lot to do with
a feel something that is hard to nail
down it has a lot to do with
ambitions or often lack thereof because
you can get things that are bad that
come in a few different flavors
you can get things that are bad but
don't realize that they're bad
and that could sometimes manifest in
interesting oddities like say the room
or troll 2 where obviously the people
making it
did not realize they were making utter
garbage
you can get things where the people
making it
know it's trash and really lean into
that
that's where you get things like well
for a recent example something like the
velocipaster
that's not my jam either for me there's
a sweet zone
right in the middle where
it is ridiculous
it knows it's ridiculous but it doesn't
lean on that like a crutch to avoid the
you know doing the basic nuts and bolts
of competent storytelling
but it also doesn't shy away from the
fact that it is ridiculous
and honestly comic book adaptation is
perfect
for this kind of trash but it took a
long time for it to get there
i mean you look back at the comic book
adaptations
for a long time honestly they were
terrified
of looking comic booky you actually go
outside in these things
what would you prefer yellow spandex
and then you finally got the 2002 sam
raimi spider-man film
which was bright and colorful and show
them hey
we can do garish it's all right but even
after that it was a
slow for everyone else to really fully
catch up because you would get stuff
like daredevil that was still darwin
even now you still get stuff
you know desaturated it's serious it's
dark it's gritty which is not to say
that can't be good but
comic books are ridiculous that's part
of what's
fun about them and even things that have
embraced the ridiculousness
like say most of the marvel movies will
still
they still have their stumbling points
with things like say
thor the dark world but
you can get into something like say
avengers civil war
which has a lot of emotional weight and
it's taken pretty seriously
but at the same time can joke around
with characters like spider-man and
ant-man
because those characters are fun and in
the case of ant-man specifically
ridiculous and yet at the same time
i don't know if uh avengers would have
put a monkey butler
in there i know they've got rocket
raccoon but he's out in space he's not
on earth
generally they don't have to justify him
not that umbrella academy needs to
justify its monkey butler
it just has sorry ape ape butler
it just has one here's the thing i saw
season one
of umbrella academy and liked it fine
it didn't become my jam until the second
season
i think the main reason for that is the
first season well
the first season really especially now
in hindsight
was just a lot of groundwork laying it
was getting us familiar with these
characters getting us familiar with
their interactions
their damage the world in general and
things going on in the background like
with the commission and everything else
but
there was a lot of setup not a ton of
plot we had all these characters
established
all the members of the umbrella academy
their father
everything going on with the apocalypse
vinya had a little bit of a plot but it
was slow moving
you had uh hazel and
but even they didn't like come in and
impact things all that much
for how long that first season was not a
lot
happened because it was mostly just a
climating everyone to
all this stuff and that can make for a
okay first season but if you build off
that properly it means you can hit the
second season
running and this one ran and it ran with
a plot that i didn't think was going to
be great like i saw the trailer you can
see my trailer reaction
when i saw that it was going to be set
in the 60s we're going to be dealing
with jfk i was like oh
god come on it seems like so many time
travel things are like ooh
can we stop jfk but like no
it's it's great and it does so many
things that i would have thought like
that's a bad idea why would you do that
and it makes it work
or at least it makes it fun breaking the
team up
so they're not all together again which
means we have to have them all finding
each other again
oh for crying out loud that feels like
stalling no because in their different
isolated patches
they are going to be in new
circumstances that is going to show us
how they adapt how they adjust or how
they fail
at that and then as we move forward and
we get to see whole new things from some
of them
alison now has a husband and rey is
terrific and amazing and thank god they
ditched the freaking crap with her and
luther yes luther's still pining for her
because luther's a dope but i'm glad
that they
stopped doing i'm glad it was also
pointed out in the universe like that's
weird
and vania i when the season started i
was
so i'm gonna try and avoid major
spoilers
i'll try and limit this to front half of
the second season
but with vanya the setup
of her coming in and not remembering
which is basically a big part of what
the reveal was last time so i'm like
great we're gonna repeat her arc
except we don't because her reaction
to learning what she you know learning
similar stuff to what she learned last
time
is not the same her circumstances are
not the same the people she's around
are not the same and so it plays
different it's not a repeated arc it's
taking the characters we knew
and doing something different with them
but while keeping all of the absurdity
and
nonsense because these characters like
five you try and look me in the eye
and tell me that a 12 year old or at
least
physically 12 year old time traveling
master assassin
who was in love with a man again
isn't a trashy idea because it is
and then there's klaus sexy trash
i relate to class a lot some for reasons
that
cut on the deep side of things but
i just i i love that without having to
sit down and explain
exactly why you can get pretty quickly
if you think about it for more than half
a second how hearing dead people
whether he wants to or not would drive
someone to drink
when he ends up in the 60s he just
starts a cult
until the pressure gets too much and
then he abandons his cult
klaus is such a mess he's
such an empathetic little bastard who
hates his own
feelings i'm sure he would love nothing
more than to deaden
every feeling he ever has had or ever
will have
but he can't and it's gorgeous and
painful and
overwrought and beautiful
allison i already mentioned she gets way
better stuff going on here than she did
in the first season largely because
she's decoupled from luther
and then we've got ben and we didn't
know all that much about ben
from the first one other than he was
dead here we learn about ben
beyond just his antagonizing class we
learn more about how he
thinks and feels about the world and
other people
what he's like what he misses about
being alive
that was touching my heart by the end
but again let us not forget
ben is a ghost who can so far as i can
tell open a portal to the elder gods
in his chest that's horrifying
and it's great luther
i mean literally just kind of just kind
of dull i won't lie
it they did a few interesting things
with him like the whole
saying to hell with it after being the
big responsible one
yeah that's that's fine that works oh
he is great when paired off against five
especially in this season
because i love first of all luther looks
ridiculous and then five
five is the one who takes pretty much
all of this the most serious out of
anybody
and he looks preposterous
it's so it's so stupid it's so great
and then vanya her arc
her story this like the first time it
actually kind of annoyed me
because i found the premise of her being
the only one who doesn't have powers in
this family of people with powers to
actually be more interested in the idea
of oh she's actually the most powerful
of them all
but here the arc just plays so much
better and they do a lot better work
with the idea of her being
a misfit among this group of misfits
it's
solid work and it's much better use of
your ellen page
than the first one and then there's
diego and
diego's just an idiot like
yeah i won't lie if diego were to drop
dead
in the next season i i i wouldn't um i
wouldn't exactly be shedding a tear
there's some great terms that get used
for him
in this season imagine batman then
aim lower you are an open book written
for
very dumb children i actually found
myself thinking that diego is a bit
well he's about kylo ren
because every word of what you just said
was wrong he never does the right
or intelligent or even common sense
thing ever
he is so stupid and yet so
self-righteous that's the thing luther's
not that smart
either but luther seems to accept when
other people tell him that he's not
doing the right thing like oh okay maybe
you know better diego is so sure of
himself and
so dumb i don't think he makes a single
sound decision in the entire season
and i can't even remember what he did in
the first season enough to say whether
he made any sound decisions in that one
and then we get further expansion of
their father
and which again much like this is better
use of your ellen page
now we have better use of your comb
fiori
this thing is a vibe it's a feel
and gotham really is my go-to comparison
for this
this is bonkers characters in a bonkers
world
dealing with dark stakes and heavy
themes
and things that honestly feel like they
shouldn't be mixed with stuff this
ridiculous or characters this
stupid and i don't just mean diego like
klaus is an idiot too
i feel for him but he's an idiot and
luther's a bit of an idiot alison she's
not stupid but she's definitely
uh matt had her questionable decisions
five
seems to have it together but boy is he
rash
and like these people that just keep
stumbling over each other
in the way that my favorite pieces
of trash media do and i am
so happy with this second season
i don't here's the thing i don't know if
i'd ever actually go back and watch the
first season again
but i will re-watch the crap out of this
it's so much fun i hope you watched it
and if you didn't i did not spoil major
plot points of the second season i did a
little bit
for the first season but you know
hopefully you've seen that already now
this is another case where i don't have
a sponsor although i do have a patreon
help me out i'd appreciate it but so
where i would maybe put a sponsorship
plug instead i am going to shout out
a creative who i think folks should look
into and would have fun with
i'm going to pick another cosplayer this
time so if you go to instagram
look up sarah and deputy cosplays
probably said altogether serendipity
cosplays but you know spelled like
like that you will find a fantastic
cosplayer
with a great variety of work a lot of it
is very
fun she's just got a great presence
she does enchanting she does scary she
does gender bending i mean
yeah so i'm gonna be a sucker for that
check out her stuff
follow her on instagram and i think
you'll have a good time seeing her work
pop up in your feed
so that's it for this one umbrella
academy season two you've seen it what
you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let us
talk about it you know all the stuff i
mentioned the patreon already keeps the
lights on
much appreciated plus a bunch of other
stuff
like subscribe share all of which help
me out uh
in its own way but at the end of the day
i'm not going to tell you what to do
because you're the council and
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
i heard a rumor that you supported me on
patreon it like shared subscribed and
hit the bell
had to try
[Music]
[Applause]
um
now
[Music]